Oppenheimer is one of the most
anticipated movies of the year one of
the many reasons for that could be its
strangely familiar leading man there are
quite a few familiar faces among the
cast for Christopher Nolan's new epic
biographical drama Oppenheimer including
Marvel Alum Robert Downey Jr and
Midsummer star Florence Pugh however
audiences may be most intrigued by just
how familiar the titular scientist J
Robert Oppenheimer himself looks to them
and it's not just because he's a
well-known historical figure as a matter
of fact Oppenheimer is portrayed by one
of Nolan's most long-standing
collaborators actor Killian Murphy
Murphy has been a notable name in film
and TV for decades at this point and all
of that time he's appeared in a number
of Nolan's most popular movies but he
has also featured in plenty of notable
Productions outside of that sphere
Murphy began work as an actor in 1996
mainly appearing in Theatrical
Productions small movies and short films
the now-renowned actors breakout role
was actually as the lead of Danny
Boyle's 2002 Apocalypse movie 28 Days
Later in the film Murphy portrays a
bicycle career named Jim who awakens
from a coma to find that Society has
collapsed due to a virus that makes
hosts incredibly aggressive together
with several other non-infected people
Jim fights to survive in a 2022
interview with enemy looking back on 28
Days Later Murphy credited the film as
having helped him establish him in the
film industry in retrospect it could
even be viewed as the first Domino that
led to his role as Oppenheimer he
explained it opened doors for me I
managed to get meetings I met
Christopher Nolan through that so it was
massive for me not long after 28 Days
Later Murphy entered the world of
superhero stardom in his first project
with Nolan 2005's Batman Begins the
first film in Nolan's Dark Knight
trilogy starred Murphy opposite
Christian Bale as the DC vigilante in
the movie Murphy plays Batman's Nemesis
scarecrow a sadistic psychologist who
uses a specialized fear toxin to drive
his victims mad Murphy's scarecrow would
only be a main antagonist for the first
movie in the trilogy but he nevertheless
returned as the character in Cameo roles
for the subsequent entries 2008's The
Dark Knight and 2012's the Dark Knight
Rises a popular bit of trivia for Batman
Begins is that Murphy initially
auditioned for the role of Batman of
course he didn't land the part but he
did impress Nolan enough to get a major
part and become one of his most trusted
collaborators while Nolan's Dark Knight
trilogy was still playing out in 2010
Murphy joined the esteemed director for
Inception the twist-filled mind-bending
Epic now considered to be one of the
best action movies of all time in the
movie Leonardo DiCaprio's Dom Cobb leads
a team in performing a dream-based heist
in order to topple a business Empire
Murphy plays Robert Fisher their
unassuming Target who gets wrapped up in
life-threatening Thrills when the heist
goes sideways
one in an interview with collider around
the time that Inception released Murphy
spoke at length about why he enjoys
working with Nolan as a filmmaker he
explained for him the performance is
Paramount it's the connection between
the actors he allows room for
spontaneity you know you would imagine
spontaneity in a 200 million dollar
movie is not particularly high on the
list of priorities but for Chris it is
not content to Simply become a dominant
force in the world of modern movies
Murphy also starred as the lead of one
of the most popular TV shows of the
2010s the gritty period crime drama
peaky blinders in the series Murphy
portrays early 20th century gang leader
Tommy Shelby throughout all six seasons
as Shelby Murphy goes to very dark and
vulnerable places over the course of the
series and his performance has been
recognized with several Awards open your
eyes but I will cut away your eyelids in
the beginning of his nearly 10-year
period filming peaky blinders Murphy had
reservations about the role however the
long-term nature of the project
ultimately turned out to be a uniquely
fulfilling experience for him speaking
about how playing Tommy was different
from any other role he's had Murphy told
Entertainment Weekly I did lots of other
things but I've never had that
experience of growing older with a
character or being able to inhabit it to
a point where the character starts
thinking for you in the performance one
of Murphy's more recent cinematic rules
of note saw the actor once again diving
into full-fledged horror while he wasn't
in the original Murphy joined the cast
of John krasinski's popular scare flick
a quiet place part 2. Murphy plays
Emmett an old family friend of the
abbots who helps Evelyn and her kids
fight back against the bloodthirsty
aliens that have conquered Earth Murphy
amps up the emotion in his portrayal of
Emmett who starts off in a Moreau State
due to the death of his family over the
course of the movie Emmett forges a
trusted bond with young Reagan and
regains his sense of humanity and hope
in an interview with the Hollywood
reporter Murphy noted that his mostly
non-verbal role in a quiet place part 2
was unique in that it allowed him to
reach back to some of his earliest
experiences acting he explained I did
theater for about four or five years
before I ever did any screen work so I
feel like I've done a lot of physical
acting and since I've continued to do
theater it was a real sort of liberating
experience to get to explore some of
that on screen
foreign